ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORIDA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN BENNETT.
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRIAN
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES TEN CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRIEDMAN. GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON RAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY LACKEY LEAD
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MCCARTY MEDINA
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN NO
WHEN. O'DONNELL PATTERSON.
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK CORK SILVA
RAMOS RAN'S THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SEE R. DEL SMITH
STONE TEAM VALLADARES REPORTER
WHAT VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
DATES PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN. YOUR
YASIR KHAN IMAM YASIR. IN THE
NAME OF GOD THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. HOW MUCH GOD
. WE ASK FOR YOUR GRACE. BUT
HEARING AND BLESSINGS BE BASED
OUT. THE MEN AND WOMEN. I HAVE
BEEN CALLED TO SERVE. OUR STATE
IN THIS CHAMBER. HELP THEM TO
REPRESENT THEIR CONSTITUENTS
WISELY. WITH AN EYE TOWARD
SAFEGUARDING THE DEEPER TRUTHS.
OF HUMAN LIFE DOT COM ONLY FROM
YOU. BLUSTER REGIONS THAT THEY
REPRESENT. BLESS OUR COUNTRY.
HELP OUR LEGISLATORS TO ENACT
LAWS DOUBLE OH HOLD THE VALUES
OF PEACE AND JUSTICE IN OUR LAND
AND THROUGHOUT THE WORLD. WE ASK
THIS IN GOD'S NAME I MEAN. THANK
YOU MY MASTER WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER FONG. A PLEASE LET ME
KNOW IF IN THE PLEDGE SALUTE
PLEDGE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. AS.
ZERO IT IS A- ALL. THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY
SACRAMENT CHAMBERS SACRAMENTO
FRIDAY SEPTEMBER TENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ASSEMBLY MET ELEVEN
THIRTY AM I AUDIBLE KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAK FOR TEN OF THE ASSEMBLY
PRESIDED CHIEF CLERK TO PARKER
AT THE DESK READING CRICKET
DAVID ABLEMAN READING THE FAULT
THE ROLE WAS CALLED. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE MOVE CUOMO CALLED THE
SIMPLY MOTION CARRIED HIGHEST
GERMAN WAR MOVES ND MISTER
FLORA SECONDS THAT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS
HAVE PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REF OF BILLS WILL
BE DEFERRED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE-
SENATE THERE ARE NONE. MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS THE AB FOR THE
DAY WILL BE DEEMED READ. AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. MR WARD
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHT
TO ALLOW SOME REMEMBER SALAS TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER I FOR THE REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
KALRA GRAY FLORA MEDINA WHEN AND
QUIRKS SILVA TO SPEAK ON
ADJOURNMENT A GERMAN MEMORY
TODAY. BEGIN WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. MISTER
SPEAKER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ IS GIVING A ONE
DAY NOTICE TO REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE ITEM THE FIFTEEN
AB FIVE TWENTY FOUR I AM A
SIXTEEN AB FIVE FIVE ONE. ITEM A. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SIX SIX TWO.
THE CLERK WILL NOW.
MEMBERS WE
HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST WITH US IN
THE CHAMBER TODAY MEMBERS.
MEMBERS MAY HAVE YOUR ATTENTION
WE HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST
INTRODUCTIONS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FROM MY
DESK IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
. MISTER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER IF THE SERGEANT TO GIVE
ASSISTANCE TO MR SOUTH ON THE
MICROPHONE ARM OR MISTER SALAS.
ACTUALLY MAKE YOUR PRESENTATION
FROM THE SPEAKERS TEST. AND
WE'LL GET THAT MICROPHONE FIXED. MISTER SOUTH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FROM MISTER SPEAKER
STATUS MISTER SALAS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS IT IS MY
DISTINCT HONOR TODAY TO WELCOME
ELAINE HALL OR FORMER STATE
AUDITOR TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
AND CONGRATULATE HER ON A WELL
DESERVED RETIREMENT. EVENT
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH ELAINE
DURING MY TIME AS CHAIR OF THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE AND I CANNOT THINK OF
A PERSON. WHO BETTER EMBODIES
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A PUBLIC
SERVANTS. THIS CALL WAS ACTUALLY
FOR CNN ON THIS ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
ON AUGUST TWENTY SECOND OF TWO
THOUSAND. S. YES SIR OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THIRTY
EIGHT YEARS TWENTY ONE OF THOSE
YEARS WERE IN HER ROLE AS THE
DAUGHTER. MAKING HER THE LONGEST
SERVING STATE WATER IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY.
ADDITIONALLY ELENA WAS
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST FEMALE STATE
AUDITOR. SHE HAS BEEN APPOINTED
BY THREE DIFFERENT GOVERNOR'S
FROM BOTH POLITICAL PARTIES A
TESTAMENT TO HER IMPARTIALITY
AND PERSONAL INTEGRITY AND THAT
SHE AND HER STAFF HAVE
MAINTAINED ELAINE WILL TELL YOU
THAT THIS WASN'T ALWAYS HER PLAN
. SHE WAS AN INCREDIBLE SOFTBALL
PLAYER WANTED TO CONTINUE
WORKING IN COLLEGE ATHLETICS.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR ROSS AND THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA SHE FOUND
HER WAY TO WORKING AT THE OFFICE
OF THE AUDITOR GENERAL WHERE SHE
EXCELLED. THE AUDITS CONDUCTED
UNDERLINGS TENURE OF HELP TO
ELIMINATE GOVERNMENT WASTE
UNCOVER FRAUD. AND PROTECT
TAXPAYERS. WHETHER IT'S ORANGE
COUNTY'S BANKRUPTCY IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES THE
ELECTRICITY CRISIS ON THE BAY
BRIDGE RENOVATION OF.
CONTROVERSY THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS OR EASY THESE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS SHE'S BEEN A
TRUSTED VOICE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. ARE THAT WE HAVE ON SHE HAS BEEN
RECOGNIZED NATIONALLY FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND HAVE WON NUMEROUS
AWARDS INCLUDING THE NATIONAL
STATE AUDITORS ASSOCIATION
DISTINGUISHED LEADERSHIP AWARD.
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN AND THE DAVID
M. WALKER EXCELLENCE IN
GOVERNMENT PERFORMANCE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AWARD IN TWENTY
TWELVE. ELENA ALSO BEEN HONORED
BY THE INSTITUTE OF INTERNAL
AUDITORS AS ONE OF ITS FIFTEEN
MOST INFLUENTIAL PROFESSIONALS
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN. AND WAS
NAMED A PUBLIC OFFICIAL OF THE
YEAR BY GOVERNING MAGAZINE IN
TWENTY TWELVE. THESE ARE A FEW
THERE ARE FEW PUBLIC SERVANTS
HAVE RECEIVED SO MUCH ACCLAIM
AND PRAISE FROM BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE. ELAINE ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I THANK
YOU FOR CHOOSING A CAREER IN
PUBLIC SERVICE IN THE- AND STATE
OF COLLEGE ATHLETICS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR DEDICATION INTEGRITY
AND GRIT AND RESOLVE. THAT SAID
I CAN'T IMAGINE ANYONE HAVING
MORE WINS A BETTER BATTING
AVERAGE. OR MORE HOME RUNS THAN
YOU DID A STATE AUDITOR. ALAIN
YOU WILL BE INCREDIBLY MISSED
AND WE CANNOT THANK YOU ENOUGH
FOR YOUR SERVICE CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE ALL BENEFITED FROM YOUR
HARD WORK AND DEDICATION. OF
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
CONGRATULATING. MR LANE HOW ON
HER RETIREMENT AND MOST THANK
HER FAMILY FOR. AND A PARTNER
FOR GIVING OF HER TIME AND
EFFORT ALL THESE YEARS. MISTER
CELIS THE NUMBER OF MEMBERS ARE
SEEKING RECOGNITION AT THIS TIME
MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AT THIS TIME. YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
WANT TO THANK- SEVEN SALAS FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- WHEN HE
WALKED WITH HER WALK INTO THE
CHAMBERS WITH ELAINE HOLLISTER
WHAT ARE YOU DOING HERE- WE JUST
SMILED I HAVEN'T SEEN HER A LONG
TIME. AND THEN I WENT TO SALAS
HE TOLD ME THAT HE WAS- SHE WAS
RETIRING- FOR SYSTEM DOES YOU
MAY NOT KNOW- I WAS THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT CHEER- IN TWO
THOUSAND. AND FIFTEEN APPOINTED
BY THAT TIME HE WAS SPEAKER TONI
ATKINS TO CHAIR THIS VERY
POWERFUL AND DYNAMIC- COMMITTEE
AND HAD THE GREAT PLEASURE. OF
WORKING WITH HER ON TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND NO ONE
DOES IT BETTER LIKE ELAINE HOW.
CERTAINLY SHE PUT HER EYES ON
HER SHE HAS A VERY COMPETENT
TEAM. VERY THOROUGH TEAM- THAT I
HAD THE PLEASURE OF WORKING
WITH- WHILE I WAS THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE JOINT LIST OF AUDIT
COMMITTEE AND TO BE ON THIS
GREEN CARPET. AND BE- AND ALSO
SEE YOU GO INTO RETIREMENT- IT
WAS A SHOCK. CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE GOING TO LOSE YOU BUT WE
KNOW THAT- YOU YOU HAVE
CERTAINLY- GROOMED INDIVIDUALS
TAKE YOUR PLACE NO CAN REALLY
TAKE YOUR PLACE BUT CERTAINLY
THE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. THAT YOU LEAVE
IN YOUR PLACE IF YOU GO ON TO
WRITE ANOTHER CHAPTER IN YOUR
JOURNEY ON YOUR JOURNEY- YOU
WILL BE MISSED. TERRIBLY MISSED
AND I AM SO GRATEFUL. AND I
WOULD SAY THE CALIFORNIA'S IN A
BETTER PLACE BECAUSE ELAINE HOW
PASSED AWAY SO THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH AND GOD BLESS YOU. A AND
M'S RUBIO YOU'RE A CLASS.
SPEAKER THANK YOU I IT HAS BEEN
AN HONOR TO WORK WITH THE LANE
FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS I'VE THE
MINUTE THAT I MET HER I KNEW
THAT IF SHE WAS OUT MOST HAVE
THE OUT MOST OF INTEGRITY AND A
DEDICATION TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND A LANE I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD
WORK AND DEDICATION TO OUR STATE
FARM MAINLY. GROOMING ME- THE
EARLY DAYS OF MY TENURE HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND BEING ABLE TO
SEE THINGS ARE IN A DIFFERENT
WAY I REALLY APPRECIATE AND
RESPECT ALL OF THE WORK THAT YOU
HAVE DONE FOR US AND I'M SAD TO
LET YOU GO WHEN YOU CALLED I WAS
LIKE NO NO. PLEASE SAY YOU'RE
NOT RETURN BECAUSE I ALREADY
KNEW THAT IT WAS COMING BUT I
WISH YOU THE BEST OF LUCK TO YOU
AND YOUR PARTNER YOU MAKE UP FOR
ALL THAT TIME THAT YOU SPENT
HOURS AND HOURS IN THE STATE
TRYING TO FIX OUR PROBLEMS
GIGGLE AND TAKE CARE OF YOUR
PARTNER TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE. AND MR PATTERSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. MICRON OKAY.
WHEN WE COME- FIRST OF ALL OUT.
I WATCHED HER FROM AFAR- AND
THEN ON THE COMMITTEE WATCHED
HER UP CLOSE. AND THEN ASKING
FOR SOME AUDITS IN JOINING
OTHERS IN GETTING AUDITS OF. EDV
ANOTHER OBVIOUS- AREAS OF
DIFFICULTY. I DON'T THINK I'VE
EVER SEEN ANYBODY SO THOROUGH.
ANYBODY WHO IS SO DEDICATED TO
WHAT SHE'S DOING- THIS IS DEEP
IN HER HEART. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT GOVERNMENT ACT JUSTLY AND
OPENLY AND CLEARLY AND HONESTLY
. AND WE HAVE HAD THAT I. M. AT
HEART. FOR US HERE AND WE'RE
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL. I REMEMBER
ONE TIME DOWN FRESNO ELAINE WAS
WITH US AND WE WERE VISITING OUR
A GROUP IN. I WAS NODDING HER AT
THE TIME AS WELL. AND REMEMBER I
SAID TO HER ELAINE. IF YOU EVER
CAME INTO MY OFFICE. WITH YOUR
STAFF. LOOKING DODD NAY. I JUST
SAY I'M GUILTY YOU GOT ME.
YOU'RE TOO GOOD. LET ME TRY TO
FIX IT. BATTLEBOTS THE RESPECT I
THINK THAT THAT THAT THAT ALL OF
US HAVE WHETHER. A WORD OF
IMPORTANT. REMINDER HERE. WE
HAVE A BIG JOB REPLACING ALAIN
HOUSE. AND I KNOW THAT THE
COMMITTEE OTHERS WE WANT THIS TO
BE S. AS THOROUGH OPEN
TRANSPARENT AND BI PARTISAN AS
POSSIBLE. AND WE WANT TO FIND.
SOMEBODY THAT WAS MOLDED. IN HER
IMAGE. BEFORE THE MOLD WAS
BROKEN. SO CONGRATULATIONS ON A
WONDERFUL CAREER THANK YOU FOR
BEING A SUB HONEST DEDICATED.
LOOKING DEEP INTO THESE ISSUES-
AND YOU HAVE BEEN IN MY JUDGMENT
THE MOST SINGULAR IMPORTANT.
ORGANIZATION AND INDIVIDUAL IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
RESPECT TO THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN GOVERNMENT AND THE
PEOPLE WE REPRESENT THANK YOU
FOR THAT SERVICE. THANK GOODNESS
PATTERSON MR GRAY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS MY FIRST
ASSIGNMENT. IN THIS
DISTINGUISHED INSTITUTION WAS
THE CHAIRPERSON OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE I
GOT TO WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE LAN HOW END TO ECHO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BRUSSELS WERE TO
ME THERE'S JUST NO FINER PUBLIC
SERVANT AND STATE GOVERNMENT.
AND I THINK IT'S A TESTAMENT TO
THAT IN AN ERA WHERE WE ALL
WATCH OUR OWN. NEWS STATIONS
THAT AGREE WITH US AND- NOBODY
CAN AGREE ON. BASIC FACTS
OFTENTIMES AMONG A SELECT
OFFICIALS. HERE'S AN OFFICIAL
WHO. IS BEING LAUDED TODAY BY
DEMOCRATS REPUBLICANS LIKE WHOSE
INTEGRITY IS SO BEYOND REPROACH
THAT NO ONE WOULD QUESTION WHO'S
DONE A FABULOUS SERVICE TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ELENA ON
YOUR WAY OUT THE DAY THE DOOR
TO- BIGGER AND GREATER AND
BETTER THINGS THANK YOU. ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA FOR YOUR
TREMENDOUS SERVICE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR FRIENDSHIP AND WHAT
YOU'VE DONE TO HELP THIS BODY.
IMPLEMENTED REALLY QUALITY
PUBLIC POLICY NOT JUST
POLITICAL- NONSENSE LIKE WE'RE
PRONE TO. BUT REALLY QUALITY
PUBLIC POLICY THAT- IS BACKED UP
BY. THE AUDITORS IN THE WORK
DONE UNDER YOUR LEADERSHIP SO.
WE'RE CERTAINLY GOING TO MISS
YOU. YOU'VE MADE AN INCREDIBLE
CONTRIBUTION FOR ALL THE PEOPLE
. IN THIS ROOM AND FOR ALL THE
PEOPLE WE REPRESENT AND I WISH
YOU THE BEST IF THERE'S ANYTHING
I CAN EVER DO PLEASE. REACH OUT. THANK THIS GREAT MISTER
MCCARTY. YOUR ATTENTION. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO WANTED
TO RECOGNIZE YOU- ELAINE HOW AND
NOT JUST YOU BUT YOUR ENTIRE
TEAM OF DOZENS OF PEOPLE BEHIND
YOU- THE PEOPLE THAT COME IN AND
REPRESENT YOU TO GET THIS
PROCESS STARTED- I'VE I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH YOU NOW FOR SOME
EIGHTY YEAR I'VE NEVER BEEN ON
THE COMMITTEE- BUT I JUST WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THE OUTSTANDING
WORK THAT YOU HAVE DONE GIVE IT
GIVE A COUPLE REAL EXAMPLES BUT
BUT FIRST MISTER SALAS MENTION
THAT YOU. OR A SOFTBALL PLAYER
FOR THOSE YOU DON'T KNOW SHE WAS
OUR SOFTBALL UMPIRE FOR A FEW
YEARS LEGISLATIVE SOFTBALL WE
HAD A CONTESTED CALLS WE HAD TO
MAKE A CHANGE BUT YOU CALL BALLS
AND STRIKES APPROPRIATELY BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY YOU CALLED
BALLS AND STRIKES LITERALLY FOR
CALIFORNIA ON POLICY ISSUES AND
YOU SPOKE TRUTH TO POWER AND ASK
THE TOUGH QUESTIONS WHETHER OR
NOT IT MADE A DEMOCRATS LOOK
BAD. THE GOVERNOR WHO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT OF THE I UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WHOEVER YOU WERE
UNAFRAID TO ASK THE TOUGH
QUESTIONS AND AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM MERCED SAID STAND BEHIND
THE FACTS AND YOU KNOW WE COULD
JUST SAY THAT BUT I GUESS GIVE
YOU TWO EXAMPLES BECAUSE OF YOU
AND YOUR YOU AND YOUR TEAMS WORK
WE LITERALLY HAVE THOUSANDS OF
MORE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS GOING
TO THE UC WHEN WE GO BACK HOME
WHEN THE TOPPINGS ARE
CONSTITUENTS ELLIS. MY KID MY
NEIGHBOR MY BLAH BLAH BLAH IT'S
GOT A FOUR POINT EXIT CAN'T GET
INTO THE UC WELL BECAUSE OF YOUR
WORK WE CHECK SHIFTED OUR
ENROLLMENT POLICIES AND NOW
LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF MORE
QUALIFIED CALIFORNIA KIDS ARE
GETTING SQUEEZED OUT AND ARE
ABLE TO GO TO THE UC. WE WERE
ABLE TO IMPROVE- OVERSIGHT
POLICIES FOR FIREARM
REGISTRATION FOR- INDIVIDUAL
CONCEALED WEAPON PERMITS AND
MAKE SURE OUR COMMUNITY IS
AND WE DON'T PUT PEOPLE AT RISK
OF THOSE ARE JUST TWO THINGS
THAT YOU WORKED WITH ME ON TO
MAKE SURE YOU BRING ABOUT
POSITIVE CHANGE I KNOW THERE ARE
DOZENS OF OTHERS AND I JUST WANT
TO RECOGNIZE YOU AND YOUR
TREMENDOUS WORK AND- I. I'M THAT
THAT THE TEAM WILL FIND A NEW
LEADER TO CONTINUE THAT. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HOLD GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTABLE AND BRING ABOUT GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THERE IS
REGARDED AS PETRIE-NORRIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. AND THAT I TO RISE Q.
WHEN MY VOICE IN THAT THE CHORUS
OF MEMBERS ON THIS FLOOR.
THANKING YOU THAT'S HOW ALL FOR
YOUR TREMENDOUS CONTRIBUTION TO
OUR STATE- I. HAVE I HAD THE
HONOR AND PRIVILEGE TO WORK
ALONGSIDE YOU AS CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY'S ACCOUNTABILITY AND-
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE.
AND THAT I'VE SEEN FIRST HAND
THE INCREDIBLE WORK. I THAT SAID
THAT YOU AND YOUR TEAM DO ON
BEHALF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND YOU KNOW THE REALITY IS
SOMETIMES WE START TALKING ABOUT
OVERSIGHT. ACCOUNTABILITY
PEOPLE'S EYES GLAZE OVER RIGHT
MAYBE IT'S NOT THE MOST SEXY
TOPIC. NOT ALWAYS THE THING THAT
GETS YOU THE MOST YOU KNOW
WHATEVER IT LIKES ON TWITTER.
BUT I THINK ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT IS MORE IMPORTANT
RIGHT NOW THAN. EVER I FEEL LIKE
AT WE'RE LIVING IN A MOMENT
WHERE PEOPLE'S TRUST IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS. PEOPLE'S FAITH IN
OUR GOVERNMENT I WILL TRUST IN
OUR LEADERS IS AT SOMETHING OF
AN ALL TIME LOW. AND THE REALITY
IS EVERY TIME EVERY TIME THERE'S
A CASE OF WASTE FRAUD OR ABUSE
ERODES PEOPLE'S TRUST STILL
FURTHER. AND THE ONLY WAY THE
ONLY WAY THAT WE AS LEADERS CAN
REBUILD THAT TRUST. REBUILD THAT
FAITH IS TO ENSURE THE I THINK
USE THAT WORD THE PHRASE THE
PERSISTENT OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE DELIVERING FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT WE REPRESENT SO. THANK YOU
AND AT NEW THAT WE WILL WILL
TAKE YOUR WORK. AS AN
INSPIRATION AS WE MOVE FOR.
MISTER JONES SAWYER. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- AS YOU KNOW I CAME FROM
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES I
PROBABLY BEEN AUDITED FIVE TIMES
WHEN I WAS WITH THE CITY ABOUT
LA. I HAVE A DEEP DISDAIN AND
DISREGARD FOR AUDITORS WHEN I
WAS THE CITY OF LA. IN FACT I
PROBABLY MADE MORE ORDER JUST
CRIED WHEN THEY AUDITED ME BEEN
ANYBODY IN THE HISTORY OF THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES. A LOT OF
TIMES THOSE AUDITS WERE ABOUT
POLITICS. OR ABOUT HURTING
PEOPLE AND IT WAS NEVER ABOUT
COMING TO A SOLUTION. AND SO
WHEN I GOT HERE. AND I FINALLY
MET YOU. YOU WERE ABLE TO CHANGE
MY MIND ABOUT AUDITORS. YOU'RE
ABLE TO MAKE ME UNDERSTAND NOT
ONLY WHAT YOU DO. BUT TO RESPECT
TO HAVE FULL RESPECT FOR WHAT IN
ORDER TO DOES IN FACT. THERE
BEEN TIMES WHERE I WANT TO GET
INFORMATION FROM THE DEPARTMENT
. AND THEY WOULD BE RECALCITRANT
OR THEY WOULD JUST BE STUBBORN
THEY WOULDN'T GIVE IT TO ME. AND
I WOULD SAY. I'M GONNA RIGHT NOT
A- I'M A HEAVY LANE HOW ARE THAT
YOU AND I GET THAT INFORMATION
LIKE. THAT THAT'S HOW MUCH POWER
YOU HAD. BUT MOST IMPORTANT
THAT'S HOW MUCH RESPECT THE
PEOPLE IN THIS BUILDING HAD FOR
YOU THAT NOT ONLY WOULD YOU DO A
THOROUGH AUDIT. BUT IT WOULD BE
INTEGRITY LEVEL WOULD BE SO HIGH
. THE DEPARTMENT THE DEPARTMENT
HEAD KNEW THAT WHATEVER YOU CAME
UP WITH THEY WOULD HAVE TO MAKE
THE CHANGES THAT ARE NECESSARY
AND IT WOULD HAVE TO PROVE TO
THE PUBLIC. AND TO THIS BODY.
THAT WHAT THEY WERE DOING. WAS
THE RIGHT THING OR THAT THEY
NEEDED TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES.
ARE NOT MAKE THOSE CHANGES AND
SO. THAT GIVES YOU HAVE WE'RE
GOING TO REALLY REALLY MISS.
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY- I
WOULD I WOULD. CHALLENGE ANYONE
THAT SOME OF THE CHANGES THAT
I'VE MADE SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE
IN TWENTY TWELVE. HAVE BEEN
BECAUSE OF THE AUDITS YOU
PERFORM. THAT PROVE THAT CHANGES
NEED TO BE DONE. IN A DRAMATIC
WAY. AND A LOT OF THE POLICIES
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW A BASED
ON WHAT YOU DID IN YOUR WORK AND
SO I COMMEND YOU. FOR DOING THAT
I THINK THE PEOPLE. OF
CALIFORNIA WHO REALLY DON'T SEE
YOU BECAUSE YOU BEHIND THE
SCENES. I DON'T THINK THEY
REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH. THEY
NEED TO GIVE YOU TO PRAY THAT
YOU NEED AS THE AUDITOR OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO
CONGRATULATIONS YOU RETIREMENT.
AND WE'RE GOING TO WE REALLY ARE
GOING TO MISS YOU. DAVID
CHANCELLOR AND MISS QUICK SILVA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. MADISON LIKE
TO ECHO AT THIS POINT AS SO MANY
PEOPLE HAVE MAJOR PRAISES BUT I
TO HAVE THE SAME- PRAISE FOR YOU
COMING HERE FROM ORANGE COUNTY.
IN TWENTY TWELVE AND KIND OF
TRYING TO MIGHT FIND MY WAY I
ALWAYS HAD QUESTIONS BUT I
WASN'T SURE EXACTLY THE WAY TO
PURSUE THOSE AND ONCE I STARTED
LOOKING INTO VARIOUS TOPICS THAT
I WAS INTERESTED IN IN SPAIN ON
COMMITTEES WERE YOU PRESENTED
SOME OF THE AUDITS- I REALLY
FELL IN LOVE WITH THE IDEA THAT
WE AS LEGISLATORS OF COURSE WE
CREATE LEGISLATION BUT ONE OF
OUR JOBS IS ALSO OVERSIGHT. IT'S
ALSO GOING BACK TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS WHETHER IT'S A FEE
THAT AND A PARK FUND THAT WHEN
WE'RE ADDING FEES WHETHER IT'S
THE LOTTERY WHETHER IT'S SURPLUS
LAND WHICH IS NOT IT IT'S GOING
ON RIGHT NOW THAT I ASKED FOR-
SO MANY AUDITS THAT I'VE SEEN
FIRSTHAND THE PARKING FOR THE
CELTS DATE OF THE UC SYSTEM THAT
I'VE HAD FIRST HAND NOT ONLY-
INVOLVEMENT WITH BY YOU WORKING
ON THIS AND COMING TO US AFTER
YOU PERFORM. THE AUDIT AND
REALLY EXPLAINING BUT ALSO THE
PART THAT YOU TAKE IN GIVING US
AS LEGISLATORS AT NEXT STEPS
WHAT DO WE DO WITH THE
INFORMATION HOW CAN WE FIX THIS
AND FOR ANY OF YOU WHO HAVE NOT
SEEN HER REPORTS. THEY ARE VERY
WELL DONE AND THEY GIVE YOU A
ROAD MAP TO PRESENTING
LEGISLATION SO WITH THAT I'M
JUST A WILL MISS YOU AS
EVERYBODY AS STATED BUT OUR
STATE WILL ALSO MISS YOU BECAUSE
WHEN WE CAN FIND SOLUTIONS TO
PROBLEMS THAT MAKES THIS GOOD
LEGISLATORS I WISH YOU THE BEST
AND CONGRATULATIONS. MS GARCIA
YOUR RECOGNIZE I THANK YOU I'M
GONNA BE RI PHONE I THINK IN MY
AREA ALONG WITH THE SPEAKERS
AREA HUSBAND OF THE CORRIDOR
CORRUPTION AND LONG BEFORE I GOT
HERE THAT'S AN EXISTING PROBLEM
AND WHEN WE DID THE WORK AND
BELL THE STATE THAT THAT
INCLUDING THE AUTHORS TO HELP
GIVE THE COMMUNITY A ROADMAP. SO
IT'S LIKE I THINK YOU FOR THE
VERY EXCITED TO THAN IN OUR
BACKYARD THE BEEN A ROAD MAP FOR
THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO TAKE
THAT INFORMATION AND TAKE THEIR
GOVERNMENT BACK NOT JUST IN
TERMS OF ELECTIONS BUT IN TERMS
OF HAVING GUIDANCE OF THE
CHANGES THEY SHOULD BE FIGHTING
FOR IN STRIVING FOR I INSULT NOT
AND THAT'S IS THE STATE OF MY
BACK IN PARTICULAR IS BETTER
BETTER OFF. I'M HAPPY THAT YOU
GET TO RETIRE BUT SAD FOR THE
LOSS THAT REDUCING THE
PARTNERSHIP IN MY COMMUNITY SUCH
AS WITH THAT OUR GRATITUDE FOR
THE. COMMUNITY THAT I REPRESENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND MR THIS
AREA. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER OF MANY
PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY SHOWER YOU
WITH COMPLIMENTS SO I JUST WANT
TO ECHO THE SENTIMENTS THAT
EVERYONE SAID THAT HAS SHARED I
JUST WANTED TO ALSO BRING TO
LIGHT SOMETHING I COULDN'T SEE
YOU LEAVE AND NOT COMMENT ON THE
NINE YEARS OF PARTNERSHIP I FELT
I'VE HAD WITH YOU. THANK YOU FOR
EVERYTHING YOU'VE DONE AND AS A
BRIEF A MOMENT OF- FOR A COUPLE
OF YEARS WHEN I SERVED ON THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL BUT IT DID
WHAT THE AUDIT COMMITTEE WITH J.
LIKE COMMITTEE HAS ALLOWED US IS
IF THERE'S THINGS THAT WE NEED
TO BETTER BE INFORMED ABOUT IT'S
BEEN A WONDERFUL TOOL IN OUR
TOOLBOX. TO UTILIZE IN ORDER TO
GET MORE INFORMATION AND
PENETRATE OR PEER INTO PREVAILS
THAT HAVE BEEN HELD CLOSED FOR A
LONG TIME- AND IN DOING SO ON
MANY OCCASIONS I WOULD JUST
APPROACH YOU. AND ASK YOU. HOW
WE CAN WORK AND ASK YOUR
GUIDANCE INSTEAD OF GIVING YOU
SOMETHING VERBATIM. THAT'S HOW
MUCH CONFIDENCE AND TRUST I'VE
HAD IN YOU I. THAT I SHARE THAT.
WITH MANY OF MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES. IN YOUR INTEGRITY.
YOUR FORCEFULNESS AND YOUR
DISCRETION. THOSE WOULD BE BIT
THOSE OF IN THE THREE KEY
ELEMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN- THAT
HAVE LED SO MUCH CREDIBILITY TO
THE WORK THAT YOU BROUGHT TO
THIS OFFICE THANK YOU- I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY SEEING YOU
AROUND AS WELL IN THE CAPITAL IN
SOME CAPACITY OR IN SOME. SOME
SOME SHAPE OR FORM. AND AGAIN
JUST THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING
YOU'VE DONE. M. MR COOLEY IN.
MISSILE ON CALLING MY JUST A
MOMENT AGO REFERRED TO YOUR WORK
AND PROVIDE A ROADMAP. I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
FOR THIS CHAMBER FOR THE LAST
FIVE YEARS. ONE OF THE GREAT
CHALLENGES OF AS EXTENDED TERM
LIMITS WAS HOW TO MAKE MEMBERS
MORE EFFECTIVE. AND YOU HAVE
ASSIST US FOR FIVE YEARS NOW
FOCUSING ON OVERSIGHT. IN OUR
STANDING COMMITTEES YOUR SUPPORT
OF THE CHAMBER SPECIFICALLY IN
TRAINING TO SUPPORT OUR CHAIRS
AND STAFF. HOW TO EXERCISE
OVERSIGHT. IT IS VERY VERY
SIGNIFICANT YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
CAN ONLY SERVE SIX YEARS IN THIS
HOUSE THE POWER OF OVERSIGHT
WENT AWAY. IT WAS EXTENDED
POSSIBLE SERVICE IN THIS HOUSE
TO TWELVE YEARS. THAT OPENS UP
THE CAPACITY OF EVERY STANDING
COMMITTEE EVERY STAND EACH YEAR
TO DO MORE THOROUGH OVERSIGHT.
AND IN YOUR ROLE AS AUDITOR YOU
ASSISTED THIS CHAMBER WE NOW
HAVE AN- ONLINE GUIDE FOR ALL OF
OUR COMMITTEES AND HOW DO
OVERSIGHT. YOU AND YOUR TEAM
ASSISTED IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THAT ROAD MAP. BUT BEYOND THAT
YOU ASSIST US EACH SESSION AND
TRAINING I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR JUST EXTENDED THE REACH OF
YOUR OFFICE. VERY MUCH THAT YOU
KNOW THE OLD ADAGE GIVE A PERSON
A FISH YOU FEED HIM FOR A DAY.
TEACH HIM HOW TO FISH YOU FEED
HIM FOR A LIFETIME. YOU'VE
DEFINITELY BEEN HELPING US
EXTEND THE CURVE OF OVERSIGHT TO
ALL OF OUR STANDING COMMITTEES.
WHICH IS VERY DRAMATIC AS TERM
LIMITS ONE FROM SIX TO TWELVE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MEMBERS LET'S GIVE MISS HOLLAND
. FINAL ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
AND
MR SELTZER AGAIN RECOGNIZE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND LET ME
JUST SAY ON BEHALF OF THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY AND ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS HI THIS IS A
RESOLUTION WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT
THE MISSILE AND THE LOOKING FOR
ONE MORE ROUND OF APPLAUSE AND
MEMBERS IF YOU'D LIKE TO JOIN US
FOR A PHOTO. THANK YOU.
OKAY
MEMBERS. WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING THE CORPORATION
SENATE BILL FIFTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS. ALL BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND ALL AMENDMENTS
WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED.
GOVERNOR'S VETOES ITEM SHALL BE
CONTINUE RECONSIDERATION FILE
ITEM FORTY FIVE. SHALL BE
CONTINUED. WE ARE MOVING TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. FILE
ITEMS FORTY FIVE FORTY SIX AND
FORTY SEVEN PASSED RETAIN.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE ARE FILE
ITEM FORTY EIGHT ACR ONE TWELVE
COOKERY. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE TWELVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GRAYSON
ANOTHER'S RELATIVE TO POSITIVE
PARENTING AWARENESS MONTH.
MISTER GRAYSON AVAILABLE ON THE
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT ACR ONE TWELVE WHICH
WOULD DECLARE JANUARY TO BE
POSITIVE PARENTING AWARENESS
MONTH POSITIVE PARENTING IS AN
APPROACH TO RAISING CHILDREN
WITH WHICH PROMOTES THEIR
DEVELOPMENT THE CAPACITY TO
HANDLE EMOTIONS AND SOLVE
PROBLEMS. AND TEACHES SKILLS
NEEDED TO HAVE HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS AT HOME SCHOOL AND
AT WORK WHEN CHILDREN GROW UP
AND A POSITIVE LOVING AND SAFE
ENVIRONMENT WITH CLEAR AND
CONSISTET BOUNDARIES THE BRAINS
ARE PRIMED TO LEARN THEY GET
ALONG BETTER WITH OTHERS AND
SUCCEED AS ADULTS. POSITIVE
PARENTING PROGRAMS ARE EVIDENCE
BASED AND HAVE BEEN EFFECTIVE
LIFELINES FOR FAMILIES IN MY OWN
DISTRICT HOPE FAMILY SUPPORT AND
FIRST FIVE HAVE BEEN LEADERS IN
PROVIDING A WIDE ARRAY OF
POSITIVE PARENTING CURRICULUMS
FOR FAMILIES THROUGHOUT CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY HOWEVER THESE
PROGRAMS REMAIN UNDERSTAFFED AND
UNDERFUNDED PARTICULARLY IN THE
WAKE OF COVERT NINETEEN. THE
PANDEMIC HAS UNIQUELY CHALLENGED
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES BY
DISRUPTING ROUTINES CHANGING
RELATIONSHIPS AND ROLES AND
ALTERING CHILD CARE AND
RECREATIONAL ACTIVITIES POSITIVE
PARENTING CAN PREVENT OR
MITIGATE THE EFFECTS OF TRAUMA
AND ADVERSITY THAT MANY FAMILIES
AND CALIFORNIA ARE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING. ALTHOUGH PARENTING
IS A NONSTOP JOB THAT DESERVES
RECOGNITION EVERY DAY OF THE
YEAR ACR ONE TWELVE SEEKS TO
BRING AWARENESS TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF PARENTING AND CARE
GIVERS TO THE TO DEVELOP WARM
NURTURING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THEIR CHILDREN AND TEENS AND
BECOME MORE CONFIDENT AS PARENTS
FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND
RECOGNITION OF POSITIVE
PARENTING AWARENESS MONTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND ASK FOR ACR ONE TWELVE
OF ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR GOLFERS.
THANK YOU RESTORATION MS
BOERNER HORVATH YOUR RECKLESS
YES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
TWELVE THAT RECOGNIZES JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AS POSITIVE
PARENTING AWARENESS MONTH. THE
ONGOING COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
HAS HAD AND CONTINUES TO HAVE A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN'S AND FAMILY. THERE'S
NO GREATER TIME THAN NOW TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
POSITIVE PARENTING AS A TOOL TO
HELP FAMILIES MOVE THROUGH THESE
DIFFICULT TIMES. I OFTENTIMES
BEGIN THE LIFETIME JOB OF
RAISING CHILDREN FEELING ANXIOUS
WITH FEAR OF SOCIAL PRESSURES
PREVENTING THEM FROM REACHING
OUT FOR HELP AND GUIDANCE.
FORTUNATELY THERE NUMBER OF
FAMILY SUPPORT SERVICES
PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ASSISTING PARENTS AND CAREGIVERS
TO POSITIVE PARENTING EDUCATION
AND RESOURCES. ACR ONE TWELVE
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF POSITIVE
PARENTING AS A WAY OF CREATING
STRONGER PARENT CHILD
RELATIONSHIPS WHICH IN TURN
CREATES STRONGER COMMUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. AND DR WEBBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
TWELVE POSITIVE PARENT AROUND
AWARENESS. I MAY HAVE THE TITLE
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER HERE AND THE
TITLE OF SURGEON AND MY OTHER
JOB BUT MY NUMBER ONE TITLE THAT
I TAKE PRIDE IN IS A MOM OF TWO
BRIGHT BRILLIANT BRILLIANT BOYS
. BEING A PARENT IS ONE OF THE
MOST REWARDING AND FULFILLING
EXPERIENCES OF YOUR LIFE. BUT
ARGUABLY ONE OF THE TOUGHEST
JOBS. NO MATTER WHAT YOUR CHILD
OR CHILDREN'S AGE ARE YOUR WORK
IS NEVER DONE. BUT PARENTING IN
THE TIME OF COVERT NINETEEN HAS
BROUGHT NEW CHALLENGES WITH
SCHOOL CLOSURES WORKING REMOTE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE THING IT'S A
LOT TO NAVIGATE FOR ANYONE BUT
ESPECIALLY FOR PARENTS. THE
QUALITY OF PARENTING OR
CAREGIVING STARTING PRENATALLY
IS ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL
PREDICTORS OF CHILDREN'S FUTURE
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH. POSITIVE PARENTING
AWARENESS MONTH IS A TIME TO
RECOGNIZE THE VITAL ROLE THAT
PARENTS INCLUDING BIRTH FOSTER
AND ADOPTIVE PARENTS
GRANDPARENTS AND OTHER RELATIVES
OR FAMILY FRIENDS PLAY AND
RAISING HAPPY HEALTHY AND
THRIVING CHILDREN. IS A CHANCE
TO ENCOURAGE ALL TYPES OF
FAMILIES TO SEEK AND ACCEPT
SUPPORT FROM FRIENDS FAMILY
MEMBERS NEIGHBORS AND LOCAL
RESOURCES BECAUSE IT TRULY TAKES
A VILLAGE TO RAISE A CHILD. I AM
THANKFUL FOR THE VILLAGE THAT
HELPED RAISE ME WHEN I WAS YOUNG
SINCE BOTH OF MY PARENTS WERE
WORKING AND I APPRECIATE THE
VILLAGE THAT IS HELPING RAISE MY
TWO BOYS WITH ME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BRINGING UP THIS
MEASURE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DR WEBER THANK YOU MEMBERS
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE RESOLUTION THE
AUTHORS ASKING THAT THE FIRST
ROLE THE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS IS FOR COAL AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS AND ACR ONE TWELVE. THIS
IS CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THERE ARE SIXTY FOUR
CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY YES HAVE IT. THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. PASS RETAIN A FILE
ITEM FORTY NINE WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL. NINE TWENTY ONE.
BY MISTER MCCARTY. AND THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
TWENTY ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY AN ACT RELATING TO FLOOD
PROTECTION MR MCCARTY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL RELATED TO FLOOD
CONTROL WITH THE WEST SACRAMENTO
FLOOD CONTROL PROJECT WE'RE IN
THE MIDST OF A MAJOR DROUGHT
HERE IN OUR STATE. BUT
SACRAMENTO IS THE SECOND MOST AT
RISK OF CITY IN THE NATION AS
FAR AS- FLOODING. THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT GOES BACK DECADES
HERE AS OUR RULES COMMITTEE CAN
MENTION OUR STATE CAPITOL HERE
IN SACRAMENTO HAS EXPERIENCED
THIS THIS WOULD MAKE A NUMBER OF
TECHNICAL POLICY CHANGES TO
ENSURE COMPLETION OF OUR
MAINTENANCE PROJECT ALONG. THE
WEST SACRAMENTO SACRAMENTO
BORDER THE SACRAMENTO RIVER-
INSURING THAT HOMEOWNERS
RESIDENCES BUSINESSES ARE
PROPERLY PROTECTED WE CAN.
PROTECT THE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE SACRAMENTO
REGION OR STATE CAPITOL HAS HERE
I DON'T THINK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS REGARDING SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ADAM
. LOCAL OF MORAL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF. WHO IS ADAMANT. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF A- THE- CLERK WILL. WELL CLOSER ALL CHINA I FIFTY
FIVE NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS. FIFTY ONE.
THROUGH FIFTY THREE PASS AND
RETAIN ON SENATE THIRD READING
FILE ITEMS FIFTY FOUR THROUGH
FIFTY SIX. PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WE DO HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR. DOES ANY MEMBER WISH
TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. C. NG HEARING
DONE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND
DAY CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AN ACT
RELATING TO HAZARDOUS WASTE. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE IN THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. MEMBERS THIS
IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. THIS IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SIXTY SIX KNOWS ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. WE'RE NOT GOING TO MOVE
TO ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. I ASK
THAT YOU TAKE YOUR SEATS AT THIS
TIME. HARM CALL REMAINS IN PLACE
. AS TAKE YOUR SEATS WE ARE
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
MEMBERS. OKAY THE. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY. MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY. IN HONOR
OF THE LATE PATRICK MANNING
SENIOR WHO PASSED AWAY ON
DECEMBER TENTH. HENNING LETTERS
LIVE DEDICATED TO SERVICE WITH
OVER FORTY YEARS AND LABOR
RELATIONS ON LAW. INCLUDING STOP
DIRECTOR TO BOTH THE STATE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE LABOR
COMMITTEES STATE LABOR
COMMISSIONER AND DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT. HE WAS
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE STATE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN. AND WAS APPOINTED AS A
MEMBER OF THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD AND THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
BOARD. AS A UNION REPRESENTATIVE
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
HENNING REPRESENTED WORKERS ON
BEHALF OF THREE LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
THE HOTEL AND RESTAURANT
EMPLOYEES AND BARTENDERS UNION
OF LOS ANGELES. AND THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL TWELVE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AS CHAIR
LABOR COMMITTEE I DEEPLY
APPRECIATE HIS COMMITMENT TO
WORKING FAMILIES. AND HOPE HIS
LEGACY WORK AND SPIRIT. WELL
LIVE ON IN OUR NEXT GENERATION
OF LABOR LEADERS. HENNING IS
SURVIVED BY HIS LOVING WIFE GINA
. FOUR CHILDREN AND FOUR
pYOU MISTER KALRA AND MISS CLARK
SILVA SAID GERMANY MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I TO RISE IN
MEMORY OF PATRICK CANNING SENIOR
NO ONE IS PACKED TO FAMILY AND
FRIENDS PATRICK CANNING SENIOR
WAS A FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR THE
RIGHTS OF CALIFORNIA- LABORS AND
A MAN OF GREAT FAITH. A LEADER
IN CALIFORNIA'S LABOR POLICY FOR
A FOR OVER FORTY YEARS PATRICK
LENT HIS EXPERTISE TO HUNDREDS
OF PIECES OF LEGISLATION AND
HELP TO NAVIGATE LABOR
NEGOTIATIONS ACROSS OUR COUNTRY.
HE WAS ALSO AN ORDAINED
PERMANENT DEACON IN THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH AND SERVE THE DYESS OF
SACRAMENTO FOR MORE THAN
EIGHTEEN YEARS HIS CAREER GOALS
AND SUCCESSES MESHED WELL WITH
HIS MINISTRY AND HELPED HIM
FULFILL HIS ROLE AS DEAKIN THAT
OF REACHING OUT TO ALL PEOPLE
WHO NEED ASSISTANCE. THIS OUT
REACH WOULD INCLUDE TIME SPENT
AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CATHOLIC LABOR INSTITUTE OF LOS
ANGELES AND CHAIR OF
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AREA
BOARD TEN. DURING AN INTERVIEW
PATRICK ONCE SAID THAT THE
ESSENCE OF HIS WORK WITH THE
COMMONSENSE JUSTICE AND THEN
HERE AND RIGHTS OF WORKERS AS
LAID OUT SO WELL IN CATHOLIC
SOCIAL TEACHING. PATRICK'S ANY
HENNING SENIOR WAS AN EXAMPLE OF
FAITH IN ACTION AND LEAVES A
LEGACY OF COMMITMENT AND
OUTSTANDING SERVICE TO OUR LABOR
COMMUNITY. HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE OF MORE THAN FIFTY YEARS
GINA AND THEIR CHILDREN PATRICK
ERIN AND MICHAEL. HIS SON
MICHAEL HENNING WORKED IN MY
OFFICE AS MY COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR AND I KNOW HEADMIRED
HIS FATHER AND DEARLY LOVED HIM.
I ASK THAT YOU SHARE MY
CONDOLENCES TO THE HANDING
FAMILY. THANK YOU MISS CLARK
SILVA MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY WE ARE
GOING TO LIFT THE QUORUM CALL AT
THIS TIME. PLEASE REMAIN SEATED
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR. MISTER GRAY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR A GERMAN
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS. ON MONDAY
DECEMBER TWENTY SEVENTH TWO DAYS
AFTER HIS NINETY FOURTH BIRTHDAY
. SERIES LOST ONE OF ITS MOST
WELL KNOWN AND BELOVED CITIZENS
. ADRIAN BURL CONDIT. PASTOR
CONDIT'S LIFE IS ONE OF THOSE
INCREDIBLE STORIES THAT COULD
ONLY REALLY HAPPENED HERE IN
AMERICA. HE WAS BORN CHRISTMAS
DAY NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN IN
LOCUST GROVE OKLAHOMA THEY
MAGICALLY OR TRAGICALLY. LOST
HIS MOTHER IN A CAR CRASH WHEN
HE WAS JUST THREE YEARS OLD.
REYES PRIMARILY BY HIS
GRANDPARENTS PASTOR CONDIT WAS A
PROUD FFA STUDENT WELL I WENT TO
SCHOOL WORKED ON THE FAMILY FARM
HE MET HIS BELOVED WIFE VELMA IN
NINETEEN FORTY THREE AND THEY
WERE MARRIED SHORTLY AFTER
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL. TWO
YEARS LATER. BASTAR CONDIT THEN
SERVED TWO YEARS IN THE U. S.
NAVY WHERE HE DROVE AMBULANCES
FOR THE FLEET HOSPITAL. BLESSED
WITH THEIR BABY SON BURL PASTOR
CONDIT RETURNED HOME TO ATTEND
TEACHING COLLEGE AND WORK ON A
SMALL DAIRY FARM. GOD HAD OTHER
PLANS FOR PASTOR CONDE WHO IN
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE ACCEPTED
JESUS AND GAVE HIS FIRST SERMON
. HE STAYED IN OKLAHOMA HELPING
TO SPREAD GOD'S WORD UNTIL.
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN. WHERE YOU
MOVED TO CALIFORNIA. YEAH NEED
FOR A NEW PASTOR POSTAL SEARCH
OUT HERE SERIES WOULD NEVER BE
THE SAME. BEIJING VELMA MOVE
WITH THEIR SONS BURL GARY.
DARRYL DUFFY. ECHOING HIS TIME
IN THE NAVY PASS ACCOMPLISHMENT
TWENTY ONE YEARS AT THE MEMORIAL
MEDICAL CENTER SENIOR CHAPLAIN
IN SERIES OR MODESTO PROVIDING
COMFORT AND SPIRITUAL GUIDANCE
TO PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
DURING TIMES OF NEED. AS MOST OF
THOSE THIS BUILDING NO GARY
CONDIT SOON EMERGED AS A
POWERHOUSE POLITICIAN. FIRST AT
THE LOCAL AND STATE LEVELS AND
EVENTUALLY IN CONGRESS. THAT'S
YOUR CALL THE RIDGELY DISLIKE
THE IDEA OF A SON ENTERING THE
POLITICAL ROUND UNTIL GET
REMINDED HIS FATHER THAT THE
POLITICS THE GOVERNMENT IS NOT
SO DIFFERENT FROM THE POLITICS.
HE HANDLES IN THE CHURCH. WITH
HIS FATHER'S BLESSING AND
SUPPORT KERRY WENT ON TO RISE TO
THE HIGHEST RANKS OF POLITICS
TAKING THE CONTACT NAME FROM.
ADRIAN'S HUMBLE ROOTS IN RURAL
OKLAHOMA TO THE HALLS OF
WASHINGTON DC. BACK AT HOME
PASTOR CONSERVE THE MINISTRY FOR
OVER SEVENTY YEARS TOUCHING
COUNTLESS LIVES WITHIN AND
OUTSIDE ITS CONGREGATION.
OFFICIATING COUNTLESS WEDDINGS.
FUNERALS DELIVERING HUNDREDS OF
SERMONS AT VILLAGE CHAPEL FREE
WILL BAPTIST CHURCH. LATER IN
LIFE PASS RICARDO WAS HONORED BY
THE CERES CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IS
THE CERES CITIZEN OF THE YEAR.
LET ME BE THE FIRST TO NOMINATE
PASTOR ADRIN KHAN IS THE CERES
CITIZEN OF ALL TIME. AND ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF
THIS GREAT MAN. THANK YOU MISTER
GRAHAM MISTER FLOOR YOU TWO ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE IN A- IN A JOURNEY MEMORY
OF ADRIN CONDUCT. FOR SO MANY
YEARS- THE COMMON FAMILY HAS
BEEN. AROUND MODESTO AROUND
STANISLAUS COUNTY SERIES AND
WHEN I DECIDED TO RUN FOR OFFICE
. I MET WITH THE YOUNG MAN IN
COOPER- WHICH WAS AGENTS
GRANDSON. COOPER AT THAT TIME
WAS A VERY YOUNG KID AND- WE ON
THE WORK TOGETHER STILL WORK
TOGETHER AS HE'S MY DISTRICT
DIRECTOR. STILLS IN MY OFFICE
BUT I'VE NEVER HEARD COOPER TALK
MORE ABOUT ANYONE. OTHER THAN
HIS GRANDPA. THAT GRANDPA HAD
SUCH AN EFFECT ON HIS LIFE AND
CREATED THE MAN H IS TODAY. SO
ON BEHALF OF MY STAFF- COOPER
WHO I CONSIDER FAMILY. RESOURCE
ADRIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEGACY
THANK YOU FOR. RAISING
INCREDIBLE GRAND KIDS AND- YOU
ARE CERTAINLY GONNA BE MISSED.
THANK YOU MISS FLORA. MR MEDINA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF DR LULA
MAE CLEMENS WHO PASSED AWAY ON
JANUARY SEVENTH IN RIVERSIDE.
WEEKS AFTER CELEBRATING HER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTH BIRTHDAY. DR
CLEMENS WAS A REGISTERED NURSE
AND EQUAL EDUCATION PIONEER AND
A CIVIL RIGHTS LEADER THE
DEDICATED HER LIFE TO
INTEGRATION INTO THE COMMUNITY.
SHE RELOCATED TO RIVERSIDE IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX WHERE SHE
FLOURISHED IN HER ROLE WITH THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AS THE DIRECTOR OF
INTERGROUP RELATIONS. AFTER
EARNING HER DOCTORATE DEGREE IN
EDUCATION FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DR CLEMENTS
TOOK A POSITION WITH THE UC
RIVERSIDE. LEADING THE TITLE FOR
SCHOOLS DESEGREGATION PROJECT
THAT COVERED FOR WESTERN STATES
. DR CLEMENS FOUGHT TIRELESSLY
FOR EDUCATION EQUITY SHE BROKE
DOWN BARRIERS AND OPEN DOORS FOR
MANY IN OUR COMMUNITY. SHE WAS
DEEPLY LOVED AND RESPECTED BY
ALL. WAS ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO
SEE HER AND TALKED TO HER ABOUT
THE DISTRICTS GROWTH WHENEVER WE
WOULD BUMP INTO EACH OTHER.
AMONG HER MANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS
AND AWARDS DR CLEMENS WAS A
DEDICATED MOTHER GRANDMOTHER AND
GREAT GRANDMOTHER. SHE IS
SURVIVED BY HER SON FRANK
MCALLISTER AND THE THIRD THREE
GRANDSONS AND THREE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AND ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF DR LULA
MAE CLEMENTS. THANK YOU MR
MEDINA THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DESK TO
PRINT IN THE JOURNAL REQUEST
RETURN A MEMORY. WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
. ANNOUNCEMENTS SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS WEDNESDAY JANUARY
NINETEENTH CHECKING SESSION.
THURSDAY JANUARY TWENTIETH THE
FOUR SESSIONS AT NINE AM. ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WOULD PASS
AND RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MS BONTA MOVES AND MR GABRIEL
SECOND SET THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY JANUARY
TWENTIETH. AT NINE AM WE ARE
ADJOURNED.